over the past six weeks we've been
focusing our efforts on moving help aids
combat along the path to completion and
in this diary we're very happy to be
sharing our progress with you so far
into the lair of the beast look it in
the eye and fight for his soul this is
your mission this is your quest
we had just finished a center war
trailer and we picked one scene and we
used that scene to really focus us on
finalizing the cinema model her
character her performance to move
everything that defines her now we
wanted to repeat that same trick but for
combat and so we picked an area of the
game that was very combat heavy and we
went for it I know it's a smaller
physically weaker than the Vikings it
was important for us to make her feel
vulnerable and not a superhero
because she's physically weaker she
needs to rely on speed and technical
ability to overcome her enemies
light-heavy Emily attacks along with
blocking and evading are our core
abilities understanding the nuance of
these and how they flow between each
other gives you a speed advantage in
combat in order to make this feel faster
smooth and responsive we have to set up
hundreds of parameters in the comedy
tours I've now created the combat editor
allows us to build edit and control
every aspect of the combat system in
real time with it Wan Chris and others
on the team can bring together
animations effects transitions sounds
and gameplay to get the effect that they
want the motion capture suit gave us a
ton of information to work with but it's
really only the start of the process
first you take an eye then had to go
through all of the data and edit and
polish it by hand to get exactly what we
needed
afterwards we then added animated
cameras and facial expressions to cinema
to emphasize her reactions in combat a
goal and the challenge for help load was
to give the player all feedback without
the use of an on-screen HUD so taking
cues from action movies everything had
to be communicated visually and with
sound every attack has a strength damage
and effects associated with it we've
built an effects table that allows us to
specify what particle effects post
effects etc get associated with each
strike
we show enemy health with invisible cuts
and bleeding and we show you senators
health with a combination of
post-process effects if I left somewhere
I get hit here you will see what spice
appear on the screen and then as you get
more wounded we bring in a business and
slowly desaturate the screen we also
added a new multi opponent system
allowing the player to switch
effortlessly between multiple enemies at
the same time these fights are very tiny
as enemies surround you from all sides
rather than pulling back the camera or
adding wide sweeping moves who instead
wanted to reinforce the idea that how
you position yourself in combat is very
very important
everything was staged so that we had a
good series of combat encounters a good
visual progression throughout the level
and a story through line that weaved it
all together
so the majority of this level is made
out of individual kit parts which allows
me to iterate and change and set dress
with speed there are some areas which
are bespoke like the hell home tower
over here in the background using real
world reference we set up the lighting
and atmospherics these can be
dynamically changed in gameplay to
portray cinemas mood then we heightened
the effects of these to give the final
look
sound is very important for
understanding combat every attack type
has a unique sound effect and vocal
quality
we also use 3d position and sound so
that you can know where in the tax comes
from even when they are attacking from
for the music we use one of Angela
Plagueis combo tracks and split it into
sections then I will tie the music
system to gameplay to dynamically follow
the action
combat development doesn't end here and
everything you've seen is still working
progress we've got plenty more to do but
we do feel like we've made some big
strides forward now we move on to our
new challenge with renewed confidence